Karla is with us in Jackson Mississippi
hey Karla how are you I'm doing very
well thank you for taking my call
sure what's up well our situation is
that there's three in the household it's
my husband and myself and my dad passed
away two years ago so momma moved in
with us so she couldn't make it on her
own so we just kind of combine our
incomes our monthly income with three of
us combined is thirty four hundred and
forty two dollars I've done the everyday
dollar budget and we're like 47 dollars
a month over budget as things stand now
we had back in January we had some
identity theft going on in our account
and that put us almost I say twelve to
fifteen hundred dollars in the hole that
the bank took for overdrafts and stuff
so that put us I mean why did the bank
charge you anything if there was
identity theft I mean well it was iTunes
that was charged to our account I know
but if it's identity theft the bank
shouldn't be charging you anything well
they did and they said there was nothing
they could do about it
I can change banks yeah we did
okay we actually closed banking and we
just have a debit card that it's like
one of those little Walmart cards you
know so we don't even go through the
bank's anymore it's just a debit card
but they charge us like six near about
$600 in overdraft and they wouldn't take
them back but during that time because
all that was going on
we got behind
own our house payments and a couple of
more things from a smaller notes that we
had well we caught the smaller notes up
but we're still too behind on our house
I've talked to the housing loan people
and they're working with us but we're
having to pay extra a month on our
mortgage payment sure how old are you
guys
59 I'm 59 and he's 60 and mom's 79 are
you guys on some kind of a fixed income
for some reason yes it's a disability
all three of us and none of you were
able to work you know I do a little side
business with crafts and things like
that what is the nature of your
disability man is a hip displacement
what's wrong with him he had he has he
had broke his back and he has a piece of
the bone that's been close to his nerve
sack and he also had doc triple bypass
surgery a few years ago when he has a
defibrillator and
so he's got like 25% of his heart is
beating so okay well what you guys have
more than anything else is an income
crisis right due to the fixed income and
that's why I was exploring that question
it does sound like you've got some
pretty serious limitations but what I'm
going to do if I'm in your shoes is what
you kind of started doing there with the
crafts and even in his shoes obviously
none of you all are gonna be involved in
physical labor of any kind okay but if
there was something that you could do
like I talked to a lady the other day
who was just going to garage sales and
she was buying clothing for a quarter
and a nickel and selling it on eBay for
$1 and $2 and she had done that like ten
thousand times and made like ten
thousand dollars and that didn't involve
any heavy lifting obviously it involved
the keystrokes on the computer to set up
an eBay account and sell some stuff on
eBay I'm not saying that's what you do
I'm just saying that something like that
that is
that that that is in line with the
limitations that you guys have because
if we can add a thousand dollars a month
only your world it would change your
life wouldn't it really yes sir would be
dramatic and how old is mom mama 79 and
how much of this 34 42 comes from her
11:47 yeah she passes away y'all got a
real problem
great so we've got to solve some of this
income issue one way or another here and
how much is your house payment they were
for 78 but they've increased it to five
that's not that's just due to taxes and
insurance going up right no okay and
what's the home worth oh it's worth
right at a hundred and ten hundred
twelve we only owe twelve five on it oh
we're doing this you know what have it
paid off sure would be good when it so I
think more than anything the the magic
wand here is some kind of an idea for
you to create some income and I don't
know what that is but I want the three
of you to sit around and talk about what
you could do
you're obviously not gonna do anything
that's physical I get that you've got
some serious limitations I understand
that and I'm not picking on you I'm just
trying to help you but it meant $1,000 a
month would change your whole life
thousand dollars a month for a year and
you pay that house off and that'd be rid
of that payment and then when mom passes
you're not in a problem and right now
you'd be in a serious problem $2,000 a
month income change you'd feel like you
were rich like you were multi
millionaires or something it would
change your life that much and so and is
that possible yes that is possible it's
very possible but you need some income
ideas some things you can do jump in and
it's probably something you jump on the
computer and sell something or whatever
and again it doesn't I don't want to put
a bunch of strain on your fizz
but you know I'm having an intelligent
conversation with you over the phone so
you could have an intelligent
conversation with somebody over the
phone sell them something right and that
that's a possible thing you can do the
the you know and it doesn't cause you to
work 40 hours a week necessarily but if
you could do anything that creates a
thousand two thousand dollars a month it
would change your world and that's
that's really what I would work on
rather than try to solve the $47 problem
that you've got what that is a
symptomatic of the fact that you're
struggling with income and legitimately
that you're struggling it's not cuz
you're lazy or something like that but
it's just him if you could come up with
any kind of a small business idea that
your husband and you could do together
and just get them get the needle to move
a little bit here man it would change
everything for you hey thank you for the
call hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]